et bien bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
sur diagonale tv c'est un prêt et un
prêt live depuis perpignan perpignan on
va suivre donc sur surimi nos échecs
tous eu tout ce blitz demain le grand
tournoi le grand tournoi de blitz de 15
heures à 18 heures voilà donc petite
annonce ici pour ceux qui auraient pas
suivi un petit peu le circuit des bonal
tv cette année on a déjà donc filmé
chartres avec on l'a vu un très très
beau très très beau tournoi très peu
trop nom de blitz très beau tournoi de
rapides au revoir avec des exploits des
français notamment loïc travadon être
extraordinaire qui a battu au tibia kof
voilà qui arrache le podium sur le fil
qu'on a eu la chance aussi d'avoir au
studio et qui étaient venus d'ailleurs
avec son maillot équipe de france et moi
j'ai mon petit maillot lavoyer stéphane
donc roi de la tête puisque c'est
perpignan les rois de la tête qui
organise ce festival de perpignan donc
est la deuxième étape de ce circuit
avant mundolsheim fin fin décembre mais
dont le 5 comme l'an dernier
très très belle salle aussi on suivra ça
en décembre alors donc pour perpignan ça
démarre demain c'est de 15h à 18h sur
imineo échec donc poursuivre tout le
tournoi de blitz et un petit décrochage
à 18 heures parce que la finale on la
passera sur la chaîne diagonale tv voile
handi fissures sur deux chaînes donc on
vous invite à vous abonner aux 2 1
voilà aux deux chaînes puisque diagonale
tv + diffusé sur sur plusieurs plusieurs
chaînes vous savez déjà
il y en a d'autres encore comme la
fédération aussi où on diffuse aussi des
des vidéos et donc pour demain c'est 15
heures à 18 heures l'heure des infos des
infos parce que je vais pas vous dire
uniquement des annonces je vais passer
un peu un peu de visuels voilà on a des
infos pour ce pour ce super tournoi de
perpignan qui débarrassé vraiment leur
première édition c'est la première
édition à perpignan et donc on a eu la
non ce matin on a eu pas mal d'annoncés
tout
long du mois d'octobre mais septembre
aussi un petit peu mais là on a eu
l'annoncent voilà delà de la venue de
donc la grand maître féminine evguenia
dolois neva qui a qui a été championne
d'ukraine qui joue régulièrement en
france notamment pour le club pour le
club de vendeuvre voilà et qui fait une
petite tournée dans le sud de la france
n'est pas la seule puisque on a aussi et
on va le voir
alors on a aussi alors il ya la locale
ça faut en parler un petit peu quand
même lucie salvador voilà qui a fait un
petit peu les titres des journaux
localement depuis un an puisqu'elle a
fait médaille de bronze ou gymnasiades
avec l'équipe de france était
sélectionné en équipe de france
et puis bon là un très bon niveau elle
peut battre
elle a déjà battu des grands maîtres
féminine justement au gymnase yade donc
pourquoi pas un exploit de de l'uci qui
qui peut tout à fait jouer les premiers
rôles dans ce festival côté côté féminin
au moins au moins et pourquoi pas mieux
bien sûr tout et tout est possible on
verra ça donc là elle donnait une
simultanée qu'elle a gagné 9 0 voilà
donc ça c'était c'est toujours sur le
site du club
perpignan les rois de la tête que vous
invite à aller voir et puis donc voilà
on a eu d'autres informations puisqu'on
a un grand maître argentin leandro
christ à qui vient voilà on le voit ici
à gauche face à fabiano caruana
fabien de clercq à nec et finaliste du
championnat du monde face à magnus carte
scène le grand magnus carsen pour pour
caruana ce sera au mois de novembre
alors évidemment des boudins tva comme
en télé c'est parti on commentera chaque
fois que chaque jour qui aura des partis
bien sûr un petit résumé on va pas faire
de direct puisqu'on n'a pas on n'est pas
sur place on n'a pas les images et c'est
pas intéressant pour nous mais en tout
cas faire des résumés jeu si vous en
êtes friands parce que j'ai pas le temps
de suivre qui a le temps d'ailleurs de
suivre des parties longues en direct
surtout quand c'est en semaine c'est un
peu compliqué donc des résumés du soir
pour ceux qui veulent suivre le match en
quasi-direct disons si vous coupez les
oreilles vous connaissez pas le score
avec vous pourrez suivre un petit peu le
match en en rapide quoi voilà en 30
minutes 40 minutes maximum un petit un
petit résumé de la journée de
championnat du monde c'est pour dire que
là elle est en crise à il est à
perpignan là il effaça caruana c'est pas
n'importe qui c'est
remettre vraiment top on a aussi voilà
une autre grand maître féminine m m
féminines c'est elinor frisk qui est
suédoise que je connaissais pas en fait
et qui voilà qui s'est inscrite à
perpignan il semblerait qu'elle vit dans
le sud de la france en ce moment et donc
voilà elle a vu qu'ils avaient le
tournant est forcément s'est inscrite
voilà donc une joueuse assez forte 1,1
autour de deux mille trois cents lots
donc capable de tout et puis bien sûr on
a le local alors on a le local le maître
international olivier tout ça mais vous
allez voir c'est pas tout il ya des
grosses surprises alors touzanne signal
signalons le quand même il avait gagné
une partie contre allende qui a été
champion du monde quand même
donc c'est pas n'importe qui tout zanele
capable de battre un peu n'importe qui
la voit un style absolument génial et
c'est un joueur que je crois tout le
monde adore vraiment toujours souriant
est vraiment extrêmement sympathique
olivier touzanne le local alors c'est
pas tout je vous ai dit puisque voilà on
à la grande surprise aussi on en a
d'autres nous aller voir tout de suite
ça devrait venir pour une connexion
ça va venir voilà ça bien voilà et oui
alors là aussi c'est un local mais c'est
pas n'importe quel local c'est christian
bauer christian houdini bauer bien sûr
capable de se sortir des situations les
plus extraordinaires rappelez vous sa
victoire dernièrement en 2015 ou
championnat de france sa troisième
victoire face à tigran gharamian
champion de france cette année
tigran gharamian et bien il ya trois ans
c'est un peu la revanche voilà bauer
l'avait emporté au départage en se
sortant d'une situation qui semblait
vraiment perdu et et non il a il est
capable de sortir des trucs
extraordinaires et des parties toujours
originale ils reviennent les olympiades
il a fait médaille de bronze du
cinquième échiquier il a beaucoup aidé
l'équipe de france a fait un bon score
je crois que l'équipe de france finit 9e
sur appelé bien ce qui est ce qui est
bien mais sur ces s'affaisser le niveau
de l'équipe de france finir dans les dix
premiers et parfois dans les cinq
et pourquoi pas un jour une médaille aux
olympiades ça fait ça fait longtemps je
sais pas s'il y en a jamais eu
je me rappelle pas enfin tout cas c'est
pas cette année mais dans les dix
premiers c'est déjà un excellent score
bien sûr et boire était là il faisait
partie de l'équipe aux côtés de bien sûr
maxime vachier lagrave etienne bacrot
laurent frayssinet il y avait du monde
et sébastien mazet aussi et romain
edouard voilà comme ça j'oublie
personnes et donc christian sera là
voilà il fait je crois le le plaisir du
boisé en quelque sorte puisqu'il habite
à montpellier donc il a accepté de
devenir devenir je vois perpignan pour
un peu encouragé la naissance de ce
tournoi évidemment c'est un grand
honneur pour perpignan de recevoir un
christian bauer dès cette première
édition
mais alors c'est pas tout puisque c'est
pas tout vous allez voir puisque si on
remonte voilà dans les informations
voilà ça a été annoncé dans le journal
local indépendant
il ya deux grands maîtres alors il ya le
grand maître miguel muñoz qui a été vice
champion d'espagne champion de catalogne
il sera là va être intéressant de voir
ce que ça va donner contre contre
christian bauer aussi il ya et il ya
bien sûr notre française ça c'est
important aussi bien sûr on est très
très heureux bien sûr d'avoir andrea
nawrot tescou voilà qui joue les
nationaux depuis trois ou quatre ans
maintenant six titres de championne de
france jeunes elle a aussi elle avait
aussi eu je crois bien podium en
championnats de france jeunes juniors
mixte puisqu'on qu'elle avait fini 3e si
je me souviens bien et elle a été je
crois vice championne d'europe aussi
voilà donc je n'en mets donc voilà
andrea qui est bien sûr un espoir aussi
français qui pourrait qui vise un sens
sans aucun doute le titre au moins deux
mètres internationales dans l'est dans
les années qui viennent c'est son
objectif on lui souhaite bien sûr d'y
arriver fait partie de cette génération
avec ses silos cerneaux là qui assurent
la relève chez les filles pile qui
confirme la montée en niveau surtout des
échecs féminin en france avec derrière
dans la roue bien sûr de marie sebag et
de amira skripchenko sophie millet époux
richard b / championne cette année mais
derrière ça pousse ça pousse et
andréanne a voté ce coup fait partie de
cette génération qui pousse et puis on a
un autre
grand maître stars aussi qu'on aime
beaucoup sur des bonal tv bien sûr parce
qu'il fait partie de l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs en france c'est le grand maître
international emmanuel bricard qui était
connu à ses débuts pour être un joueur
vraiment extrêmement atypique il doit
lui il lui reste toujours de sa bien sûr
toujours il jouait des débuts vraiment
vraiment qui faisait peur qu'ils
auraient pu faire peur à des joueurs
classiques des jeux des débuts très très
étrange et mis dans lesquels il met sur
l'excellent et il était extrêmement fort
et il a été champion de france 1993
voilà donc il m'a donné le plus de
cartes sera présent à perpignan ce qui
fait beaucoup de grands maîtres on en a
cinq puisqu'on a aussi en allemand s'est
inscrit à récemment sébastien je suis
bidon jeu donnera le rappellera de même
c'est un grand maître allemand qui
viennent spécifiquement à perpignan oc
et qui fait le nombre de grands maîtres
qui le porte à 5 puisqu'on a donc
emmanuel bricard on à christian bauer on
à miguel muñoz on allait au leandro
kreesha donc on l'a vu tout à l'heure
face à carolina en photo et enfin donc
c'est tellement sébastien sebastian
j'ai pas le nom en tête scène allemand
et ça reviendra et regarder une petite
photo de dali mais oui parce que à côté
du maître international catalan à retour
au vide arte qui a été champion de
catalogne
donc il a aussi de perpignan il vit de
pas loin il vient de barcelone donc
forcément à perpignan je vous rappelle
que c'est pour ceux qui savent pas c'est
comme la capitale de la catalogne nord
est puis mais sur la capitale catalane
succès barcelone barcelone n'est qu'à
une heure une heure et demie de
perpignan perpignan qui se retrouve un
petit peu au milieu de perdre de
barcelone toulouse et montpellier ce qui
en fait un point tout à fait central est
très central pour daly daly qui s'y
tient une pièce d'échec de son jeu
d'échecs il avait créé le grand le grand
artiste salvador dali en hommage à
marcel duchamp marcel duchamp notre
grand artiste français qui était aussi
un grand joueur d'échecs puisqu'il était
membre de l'équipe de france il a joué
les olympiades marcel duchamp c'est tout
à fait énorme et la dali lui a rendu
hommage en créant un jeu d'échecs où là
c'est je crois que c'est un fou je crois
avec qui est fait avec son doigt avec
son doigt on voit l'ongle en haut il ya
un petit article sur le site des rois de
la tête sur sur salvador dali ce je vous
invite à aller le voir
c'est vraiment sympa c'est la ville un
petit peu de saveur dali perpignan c'est
pas la seule il ya aussi caraquet s'il
ya une ville à côté mais c'est un
catalan comportera 10 qui avait dit de
la gare de perpignan que c'était le
centre du monde pour des raisons qu'on
peut voilà la ligne n est donc que vous
invite à découvrir taper centre du monde
d'ali sur internet et et vous allez
trouver sur des vidéos des articles sur
sa ou même perpignan salvador dali vous
allez trouver pas mal de choses c'est
vraiment intéressant à avoir donc voilà
c'est la ville de dali c'est la ville de
perpignan
voilà c'est c'est cette gare qui
s'appelle aussi il ya un centre d'el
mois là il ya vraiment un centre d'el
monde
autour de la gare est d'ailleurs un des
hôtels partenaires du tournoi s'appelle
comme ça le centre d'un centre damon et
centre du monde
en hommage à salvador salvador dali
voilà à perpignan voilà donc voilà pour
ce tournoi vraiment très original dans
une ville voilà qu'on a dans laquelle on
n'est jamais venu pour filmer voilà
c'est la première fois
c'est la première fois et c'est une très
belle ville aussi qui mérite vraiment le
détour à visiter centre-ville absolument
magnifique avec des châteaux très ancien
le palais des rois de majorque que le
castillet le canal qui traverse la ville
voilà c'est vraiment une ville tout à
fait magnifique et pour venir chose
échec c'est vraiment idéal d'autant que
la salle en plus donc est vraiment très
proche de la gare puisqu'elle est à à
peine cinq minutes à pied
une salle qui est assez jolie d'ailleurs
est assez grande
j'ai eu la chance déjà de faire un petit
tour et ça ça vaut le coup voilà donc
voilà donc c'est demain samedi à 15
heures jusqu'à 18h sur une mine aux
échecs
et puis et bien une autre annonce sera
faite sur la chaîne diagonale tv pour
compléter expliqué un petit peu le le
déroulé aussi du rapide qui sera
intégralement par contre lui diffusée
sur sur des gonades tv à la fois le
tournant et la finale voilà c'est ça
aussi la nouveauté c'est que ce tournoi
va proposer pour une des premières fois
en france pour notre club l'aspom aussi
l'aspom à bordeaux faisait ça le top 16
il appelait ça un tournoi a suivi de
match par élimination là en l'occurrence
c'est le tour à la fin du tournoi les
deux premiers s'affrontent pour la
première place en match aller retour et
ça nous donnera une belle finale sous
les caméras donc ça change un petit peu
d des formats open où on connaît le nom
du vainqueur disons souvent une ou deux
rondes avant la fin est bien là non
quelles que soient les leaders du
tournoi il faudra que les deux premiers
s'affrontent et ça va forcément donner
au spectacle une toute autre couleur
voilà donc
merci d'avoir suivi cette petite vidéo
d'annonce surimi nos échecs bon vous
savez qu'il ya pas beaucoup de ya pas
forcément énormément de vidéos nouvelles
chaque année sur l'île aux chiens mais
parce qu'il ya déjà beaucoup beaucoup de
vidéos mais elle a toujours y en a
toujours
il y en aura y compris pour le
championnat du monde car scène car
rihanna y en aura mais yahia pour les
deux chaînes puisqu'on il ya des
partenariats différend avec ses deux
chaînes et des gones à tv vous contenter
tout le monde
voilà donc abonnez-vous aux deux si vous
laissiez diagonale théval intégralité
sinon vous risquez raté bien sûr des
événements sur l'une ou l'autre voilà
donc merci d'avoir suivi ça et donc je
vous donne rendez-vous pour ceux qui
veulent suivre en direct le tournoi
d'abord de 15 heures à 18 heures ce
conte pas le temps et qui veut regarder
que la finale c'est un 18h en direct
et puis bien sûr ce sera en différé mais
une finale de blitz ça va être quand
même ça va être pas mal ça va être pas
mal mais fine et du rapide va être
peut-être encore plus intéressante parce
qu'elle sera plus longue et sur les
parties rapides c'est plus long que les
blitz qui sont les parties est clair
donc encore plus rapide que les rapides
les blitz
voilà donc dès demain 15 heures 18
heures à 18 heures changement de chaîne
diagonale tv pour la finale dimanche de
diagonale tv si vous la hanse avoir
peut-être un peu plus vous allez sur la
chaîne diagonale tv et il y aura
peut-être quelques informations
supplémentaires
ciao à bientôt sur des modèles tv